欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
这一小节我们来讲一下关于橱窗什么时候优化,怎么样去优化
一般我们优化橱窗都是选择周二这一天去优化的
因为这一天刚好是完整的周数据出来
那么我们可以通过周数据去判断橱窗的效果
同时呢我们也可以通过周数据去选择一些更有潜力的产品
去替换, 橱窗里面效果差的产品, 第二个, 并不是所有的橱窗都要优化, 我们优化橱窗, 只针对效果差的产品, 替换即可, 其他的可以不动, 如果效果好的, 或者是你的核心主推的产品, 直通车推广的, 顶展, 问顶等等, 都在, 使用资源的产品, 也可以保留在橱窗里面, 第三个就是, 我们每周,
每周都一定要去选择一些有潜力的产品,加入橱窗替换掉原始低效果的产品,那么我们现在来后台演示一下,首先我们来打开后台的橱窗板块,首先这里就是我们橱窗的一个整体的一个效果,这是橱窗的数量,这是未开通的橱窗,如果你有没有开通的,那么它会在这里显示,像我们这里看到服务中的橱窗有60个,
60个的话,你就按照周,比如说,你看,我们的是按照周来看的,看到没有,每一次更新的数据都是以周来看,更比较准确,这里是5号到11号,那么我们来看一下它的效果,替换掉哪些产品的效果,差的那些呢,比如说,这里是点击寻盘订单,那么我们来看,如果点击量都极少的,比如说像这种,点击量极少的,
但是他寻盘很多的, 这种情况, 那么我们就可以
再考虑留他一周, 再继续观察他的效果
如果像这种点击量非常低, 但是他寻盘啊, TM, 这些什么都没有的, 这种, 像这种的
就要考虑直接替换掉
比如说像这种,直接替换掉
如果你想不替换的话, 那么你可以把这个产品, 把这个产品去搜索一下, 在产品分析里面去搜索一下, 他最近
一个月或者是最近两三周的数据如何再决定要不要更换你看这里就就这些同时你看我们看比如像这种的也是要替换掉的如果是他本身数据就不好了比如说我打开他我去把它放到我的产品分析里面去看我看他最近两周的数据或者是三周的数据你看我们这里对应的45周看到没有
2号到11号是一一对应的
你看这里的话效果差
上周45周效果差
那么44周效果也很差
43周效果也很差
也就是他近三周的效果也很差
像这种情况
这个产品就直接
去替换掉他就可以了
另一种情况呢
比如像这种
分数太低的
肯定是尽可能的
少放
你可以放一些
极具潜力的产品
但是这种如果量不要放太多
这种类型的产品然后我们再来看前面的这些一些案例比如说我们来看一下刚才讲的这个比如说这个你看他的点击量很少但是他有寻盘这种产品我们去看一下他的之前的效果是怎么样的我们还是一样来到这里看先看从最新的一周看起那么从45周那么他有有订单但是他的没有寻盘这种情况这也是说明什么说明这个产品
这些订单都是业务员绑上去的
并不是客户直接下单的, 这些订单都是业务员绑上去的, 客户下单的, 概率就是极小的
如果像这样的话, 因为你已经有一定的订单数据沉淀了, 建议就是继续绑定, 继续观察, 看看他能不能拉升他的一个整体的一个点击量
另一个的话, 我们怎么样去挖掘我们的潜力的产品来进行
替补刚才那些, 我说的数据差的那些, 我们移走了
是不是我们要去找一些替补的产品
替补产品的话我们从这里找到45周按照寻盘降续来排
我们看一下这些是标识是橱窗这些标识是橱窗
我们找到没有橱窗标识的但是效果很好的
你看这个
寻盘多但是没有这个没有绑橱窗的
是不是我们可以把这个产品加入到橱窗这里呢
把它替换成把那些差的替换呢
这个产品就可以把它替换, 同时呢,我们还可以去看一下我们这个产品
到底是不是优品还是爆品
也属于准爆品,也就是他还没达到爆品,但是效果还是挺好的,而且他需要
加速一下他的流量的拉伸,所以说准爆品这种产品加入我们的整个
橱窗是非常有用的,像这种产品,还有向下看一下这些有
标识的都是橱窗, 这个基本上我们看
第一页就可以了, 我们第2个情况就是看他的Tierm之旋的元素, 我们也是找没有标识的, 没有橱窗标识的
看看哪个没有橱窗标识, 比如说这个没有橱窗标识, 没有橱窗标识, 但是他是有
悬盘的, 但是量太少了
像这种量太少的, 我们可以去看他
近三
周的数据
比如说我要看他近三周的数据
这样的话通过拉长它的时间维度来判断你看前面这些效果不是很好那么这个的话暂时考虑不佳因为你看它前几周效果都很差所以说没必要马上加入那么就按照这种思路去做你只要知道这些思路和方法你就针对你店铺里面的产品按照这些方法去操作就可以了那么这个就是替换橱窗的方法因为橱窗它是在逛部的首页可以展示
给更多的人看到所以说这里的排序我们一定要自己排手动排去排序手动去排序把我们越是阻挡越是优势的产品全部排在前面按照这个顺序排你后面的是怎么排都可以但是前面的15到20个要用手动排第2个就是橱窗卖点的设置一定要去选择更加精准的一个橱窗卖点因为这些卖点的话
会在首页搜索的时候会展示
比如说我搜一个词,搜一个词
绑定橱窗的产品我们一看就知道是哪些了
这里这里这些就是橱窗的卖点
这也就是橱窗的卖点
这一排都是橱窗的卖点
你要去设置,设置好的话
那么这些也是能够给你带来一定的吸引买家的一些内容的
所以说橱窗卖点一定要尽量的去设置
把它设置最少最少三个
这样设置满
这样就更好了
比如说你可以做一个表合
去统计这些橱窗
哪个替换了你就在背后后面备注好就可以了到时候你就知道哪些替换的效果好哪些
替换的效果差最后面我们来讲一下
我们换完橱窗之后
下一周二
一定要去对比一下你这个橱窗的前后效果
只有对比了才知道我们哪些橱窗替换是有效果的
你就根据你替换这种类型的橱窗有产品有效果的时候你后期就按照这种迟路去替换就可以了比如说A这款产品这种类型的产品我加入橱窗之后它的效果非常好那么下一次我也是找A这种类型的产品加入橱窗这样的话效果就会更好另一个加入橱窗产品的话我们还可以在这里选择
比如说这里面会有很多种平台的新品, 爆品还有原石利优品, 这些我们都可以加入橱窗, 如果你的橱窗比如说60到70个橱窗, 但是呢你的爆品可能就有3到10个, 那么还是不是还剩下很多橱窗是空余的, 橱窗空余的话我们可以先从准爆品这里面去选, 准爆品的话是非常接近
爆品的这个数据的, 也就是他可能差几个循环, 或者是几个订单, 就成为爆品了, 所以说我们把流量给到这些准爆品, 拉升他的数据, 让他更快的达成爆品这个指标, 那么接着选的产品就是平台的新品, 新品, 这些也可以选, 跟实力优品也可以选, 后期平台会更新各种流量池, 多个流量池, 那么这些流量池里面的产品,
你都可以去选
反正这些
流量池里面的产品统称为优品
那么这些优品你都可以选择更好数据的加入到我们的橱窗里面
这样的话效果会更好
这节课我们就先讲到这里主要是关于
怎么样去选择产品和怎么样去优化橱窗产品
那么我们下节课再见